[Music]
so I'm 10 years old and like every other
girl I love going to school but I also
liked missing school one day or two I
remember the first day I received a
notification from my teacher saying that
we wouldn't have classes the next day
and then the next day I received another
notification with one more day without
classes but then one day became one week
and one week became one month in one
month a couple of months then the entire
school year had to be readjusted for the
amount of classes we were missing don't
think I was on vacation mode during that
time no I will be walking down the
streets with a little pot my mom gave me
and that I would use as a drum to go
perfectly well with my chantings noon
passo trois frere new ambassadress
Pereira which means not one step back
this was 2002 in Caracas Venezuela in
the first oil strike opposition leaders
organized to protest against the
government this picture was taken a
couple of weeks ago people still
protesting in the same streets against
the same government 17 years after that
strike if you happen to read the news
you've probably seen Venezuela in the
headlines over the past months
words like hyperinflation crisis unrest
are fairly common but what I see in this
picture is larger than that
I see the hands of people I know like my
mom and my dad that still live there and
more recently I see hope hope of someday
being able to come back to it I go home
with this talk I want you to understand
what is going on in Venezuela now but I
also want to show you the nation behind
the news I want to show you the despite
the crisis there is a strong social
fabric
built in Venezuela that is worth
standing for but to do that let's travel
back in history for a bec recognize this
face this is watch Alice he was elected
as president of Venezuela in 1999 with a
populist proposal that came to change
the traditional politics of what was one
of the wealthiest countries in Latin
America he would stay in power for 14
years until he died during that time the
price of an oil barrel multiplied by 10
in considering that we sit on top of the
largest oil reserves in the world you
would expect Venezuela to become an even
richer country but no instead the
government increase our foreign that
destroyed our internal production
capacity and fueled an overwhelming
amount of corruption that left the
country in misery by 2013 the Year
Chavez died I was graduating from the
University and I had spent my five years
in college fighting against the
government all unsuccessful new
elections were scheduled and Nicolas
Maduro announced by the government's
propaganda Chavez his son was elected
president he would stay in power for six
more years terrified I left the country
as part of one of the large migration
waves waves that fled Venezuela since
then
oil prices plummeted and years of
mismanagement wrong public policies and
no investment in infrastructure
whatsoever came to a surface when isola
progressed towards one of the worst
socio-economic crisis of our times
please look at this graph we are
compared to Syria without actually being
war our annual inflation rate is
estimated in somewhere between 1.6
million and 10
million percent can you imagine that 90%
of our population lives under the
poverty line
children have to scavenge for food in
the streets and babies are dying in
hospitals because antibiotics are
nowhere to be found so what is happening
now by the beginning of this year
Maduro announced he would continue with
his presidency and he had the support of
a few countries like Russia Cuba and
China at this time after years of
fighting against the government we are
fighting for a government one way though
is the president of the National
Assembly and he announced by the end of
this year that would he would be
stepping in as interim president I have
to explain a bit better what this what
all of this means years ago we like to
the National Assembly we all voted for
an maroudo last year decided to strip
away the power of this National Assembly
I created a new one it is as if
President Trump decided to create a new
Congress of Republicans because the one
in power is fully Democrat and even
worse this National Assembly call for
presidential elections that were a fraud
and that's where mehoudar won so Huang
way though the president of the National
Assembly we had elected is following
articles in our Constitution and is
legitimately announces his presidency
immediately millions of Venezuelans
started supporting him and that's the
picture I showed in the beginning of the
talk not only Venezuelans we have the
support of the international community
over 60 countries have already
legitimized his presidency including the
US
the European Union and our neighbors
Colombia and Brazil now don't get me
wrong there's still a lot of
uncertainties and I don't really know
what will happen but maybe just maybe
this time we do change things and a new
government starts for the first time in
my life I felt that coming back is a
possibility that the notion of
rebuilding my country is actually not
that far that is an amazing feeling to
have I need you to understand something
about countries in crisis there is never
just one side to a story that little
girl that wandered the streets in
Caracas did not grow up in this reality
the country I love is much more than
this that's this is where my family
lives this is where I learned how to
ride a bike this is where I did the most
mundane things like watching the
notebook with my best friend and crying
silently over that and I can tell you
something I am not alone
I can proudly say that there are
millions of Venezuelans that love our
country and that are fighting now for
their better future
despite the daily struggles regular
civilians like you and me are solving
for the inefficiencies of a failed state
we are threading a social fabric
fueled by creativity innovation and
above all resilience as an example if
you hopped on a bus in Caracas today you
might catch the boss TV this is an
initiative created by a group of young
journalists that worried about the
censorship of our national TV decided to
ignite champion change themselves and in
a very simple that if I
the way they showcase the news to the
lowest classes in Caracas like them we
have medical students that create a
first aid groups to support in the
violent protests and we have hundreds of
nonprofits that are increasing their
mission to cover four basic needs
there's episode for example the one I
work with that is originally focused on
sustainable tourism but it's now
reinventing itself to also provide
energy to communities that desperately
need it this is what we Venezuelans are
doing but what can you do well moving
forward will require a lot of help from
abroad and there are a couple of ways
you could be part of it first through
humanitarian aid and donations second
through votes in favor of certain
decisions in your own countries and
three by leaving this room and share in
this message help me raise awareness I
hope the next time that you read news
about Venezuela or any other country in
crisis you're curious enough to go
beyond the surface and look for the
rebuilders I can guarantee you'll be
positively surprised thank you
[Applause]
[Music]